أعني أنني لا أريد أن أكون
دراميًا بشكل مفرط ولكن
أه إنها كارثية للغاية
[موسيقى]
لقد أثرت كورفيت 19 على صناعة السياحة في
وقت كبير لأنه
لم يحدث شيء في جميع
النزل الآن كل المخيمات
كل عملية كاملة كل شيء مغلق
هناك  هناك الكثير من التأثيرات الثانوية التي
تتجاوز تأثير
قطاع السياحة نفسه
على هذا الوباء
[الموسيقى] ،
إنه لأمر مدهش مدى قربه من إمكانية
إلقاء نظرة على كيفية
خدشه كلما قضينا
وقتًا هناك في الأدغال نحمي
الحيوانات
من الصيد الجائر ، فأنت تعلم عندما يكون
كل شيء جاهزًا وجريًا ،
لديك العديد من المركبات التي تتجول
هناك ، لديك معسكرات لديك ضيوف
طوال الوقت ،
فهي تحافظ على الصيد الجائر منخفضًا جدًا ،
لذا لدينا الآن مساحات كاملة من البرية الأفريقية
التي ليس لها عين واحدة
تجنب أي شيء وبعد ذلك ، أصبح
بإمكان الصيادين الآن أن يكونوا
أكثر عدوانية وأن يتجولوا بحرية
دون أي نوع
من الدفاع ضدهم ،
فليس هناك الكثير من الناس على حق  الآن
على استعداد للجلوس هناك ونقول
لنذهب في رحلة سفاري في 2021 أو
20 في أواخر عام 2020 لأن هناك الكثير من
عدم اليقين ، كل ما يمكنك فعله الآن هو
توفير أفضل تجربة عبر الإنترنت
[موسيقى]
ممكنة
[موسيقى].
تم
بث رحلات السفاري الحية ، كان من
المثير للاهتمام أنه
قبل الحدث السري 19 ، كانت نسبة المشاهدة في
أي وقت حوالي ألفين
ومائتين إلى ألفين وخمسمائة
مشاهد وبعد أسبوعين إلى أسبوعين ونصف
، اقترب الأمر من ثلاثة عشر
ويمكن الآن لنصف ألف
شخص الذهاب في رحلات السفاري
والاستمتاع بها ونأمل أن يزرعوا
بذرة يعودون بها إلى جنوب إفريقيا
ويجب ألا يتوقف الناس عن القيام
برحلات السفاري لأن الفيروس التاجي
مؤقت ، فلدينا فيروسات
جاءت وذهبت
ما يمكنك فعله الآن هو البحث
عن جامعي التبرعات الذين سيواصلون
مساعدة الحياة البرية ، ولكن
بمجرد انتهاء الوباء عند البدء في
التخطيط لعطلتك المقبلة ،
انتقل إلى هؤلاء  الفكرة الرئيسية
هي حماية الحيوانات والمحافظة عليها
وتركها للأجيال القادمة ،
لذا
فلنكن إيجابيين ، فلنأمل أن يختفي كورونا
وسنعود للسفر مرة أخرى
أنت